[Musique]
bon alors leur
installation en direct dernier marseille
bonjour merci beaucoup d'affinités
politiques ce matin de marseille merci
d'être avec nous au sénateur des
hauts-de-seine président du groupe union
centriste ici au sénat et on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre donc jean fabrice rien de bon
joueurs vers la cei bonjour et on va
évidemment parler du remaniement ce
remaniement qui est imminent est ce que
vous souhaitez que des aînés entre
gouvernement
et le gouvernement il est fait par le
présent la république et la première
ministre à ma connaissance personne n'a
été contacté
ah non j'ai reçu aucun coup de fil
d'ailleurs un peu étonné que
je suis belle gouvernement qui cherche
une majorité ils pourraient ils
pourraient me téléphoner à tous les
groupes pour au moins connaître leurs
sentiments
lui à huit jours
comme tous les présidents de groupe elle
m'a appelé
rien de très novateur c'est un coup de
fil de politesse ont été insuffisamment
pour connaître votre opinion savoir si
le groupe union centriste était prêt à
travailler
des juges je lui ai dit ce que j'avais
dit publiquement comme d'autres groupes
d'ailleurs l'on dit nous avions toujours
été ouvert à la discussion vous avez
toujours souhaité faire aboutir des
textes dans l'intérêt du pays et des
français
au sénat on peut pas dire qu'on a été
toujours très considéré outre est
entendue j'espérais que on pourrait
travailler suivant une méthode plus
comment dire qui permet davantage
d'aboutir vous en déduisez que
gouvernement au président de république
n'ont pas besoin des centristes
l'élu dei en particulier tj pas d'avis
sur sur la question c'était au président
de la république et la première ministre
de faire des choix nous nous sommes
ouverts à la discussion nous sommes
ouverts à travailler sur sur l'ensemble
des textes comme on l'a toujours de
quelle manière je servais marseille
parce qu'hier il y avait un indiscret
dans le journal du dimanche qu'ils aient
connaît déjà les choux qui est le
président du conseil départemental de la
mène ce qui est aussi une secrétaire
général de lui dis parce que vous avez
d'autres fonctions au sein dudit il
disait qu'il fallait qu des entre dans
une coalition de gouvernement est ce que
c'est votre avis écoutez on le fera on
en parlera à l'occasion d'un congrès à
l'automne il ya comme dans toutes les
formations politiques aujourd'hui des
voix qui s'élèvent les uns pour dire on
est dans l'opposition et ya aucune
raison qu'on n'y soit plus puis d'autres
qu'il allait vous vous voyez ça c'est
vous vous dites on est dans l'opposition
n'y a aucune raison qu'on ne soit plus
non moi je pense que
il ya des sujets sur lesquels on a
travaillé surtout dans un contexte
aujourd'hui où il n'y a pas de majorité
à l'assemblée nationale est globalement
au parlement donc moi je suis pour que y
ait un travail ouvert qu'on travaille
sur des textes
majorité
un accord de gouvernement non
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas d'accord de
gouvernement ne serait ce que parce que
le gouvernement ne le souhaite pas il
sait pas il n'a pas ouvert une
discussion avec les groupes pour dire
est-ce qu'on peut s'entendre sur un
programme comme ça cela a été fait en
allemagne ça demande du temps vous
regrettez ça non mais c'est un choix de
méthode c'est pas celui qui a choisi la
première ministre est d'accord mais
autrement vous vous l'auriez souhaité
non mais jusqu'à présent il y avait une
politique qui se traduisait par une un
comportement verticale très verticale
bon il y avait une majorité à
l'assemblée bon
division quand même au sein de votre
parti est ce que lui dit va se scinder
en deux entre ceux qui va le rester sur
la ligne des républicains et ceux qui
veulent faire l'objet d'un vote au
congrès et on verra quelle ligne
l'emportent aujourd'hui chez nous il ya
des gens qui sont favorables à
travailler avec la majorité d'autres qui
le sont un peu moins bon je peux pas
vous dire dans quelle proportion
ça se passe les votes seront pourrait ne
pas rester unis
écouter durant la dernière mandature
quand il s'est agit par exemple de voter
pour donner la confiance edouard
philippe ou à d'autres
une moitié de mon groupe a porté son
vote au gouvernement une autre moitié
s'est abstenu ça a été le cas d'ailleurs
dlr aussi si vous avez a voté la
confiance quoi
écouter ce qu'ils vont nous raconter je
suis assez strictement rien avant de
voter par principe ensuite je dirais que
je trouve plutôt sur l'abstention pour
ce qui me concerne c'est l'abstention
est ce que vous êtes encore sur la même
ligne que la majorité sénatoriale de
droite gérard larcher mais il dit on est
dans une position constructive est-ce
que c'est aussi votre ligne est ce qu'il
ya quelques divergences
il ya une majorité sénatoriale parce
qu'on discute justement entre nous il ya
des sujets sur lesquels on est d'accord
on est souvent d'accord puis à des
sujets sur lesquels on n'est pas
d'accord ce qui est normal les
républicains font leur choix j'ai vu que
là il avait un certain de préconisations
sur le texte pouvoir d'achat il ya un
certain nombre de leurs préconisations
que nous partageons d'autre que nous ne
partageons pas
le sénat est le ca dans cette période un
peu trouble à ou bien pas de majorité
qualifiée est ce que le sénat peut
joindre le particulier point de vue bien
sûr le sénat le sénat a été évitée si je
puis dire pendant cinq ans
le gouvernement s'est appuyée pour
l'essentiel sur l'assemblée nationale
sur sa majorité à l'assemblée nationale
elle n'a jamais cherché véritablement à
travailler avec le sénat je pense qu'il
y avait quelques rancoeurs à la suite de
la sphère benalla de la commission
denquête et puis on est resté là dessus
et chaque fois qu'il fallait travailler
les ministres accélérer quand il passait
devant le sénat bon aujourd'hui
notamment avec le renversement j'allais
dire de majorité au sein de la cmp
commission mixte paritaire le
gouvernement ne peut pas faire
l'économie d'un dialogue avec le sénat
réunion des députés ont trouvé un accord
sur un texte et il se trouve que la
droite et le centre va se retrouver
majoritaire lors de ces cnt mais de
quelle manière vous allez vous servir de
cette force que c'est quand même un
pouvoir pour tomi du coup vous allez
être vous allez dire mais on bloque les
textes si on n'est pas écouté le texte
beaucoup est ce que vous allez être
quand même dans une forme de compromis
je pense que tout le monde part j'ai
écouté ce que disait bruno retailleau
j'ai écouté ce que disait olivier marc
l'ex tout le monde part avec l'idée
quand même d'essayer de trouver des
solutions ce n'est pas de bloquer c'est
de faire prévaloir un certain nombre
jaillir de préoccupation et dire voilà
vous nous proposez ça donc vous propose
ça comment on peut s'entendre et il faut
il va bien falloir trouver des solutions
la tuerie sur le gouvernement sur la
question des violences sexuelles
trois personnalités de haut rang sont
concernés par des plaintes un ou des
alertes pour violences sexuelles
selon vous qui est rompu à l'exercice
politique est-ce qu'il doit y avoir un
principe de précaution pas au
gouvernement ou sur des hautes fonctions
des personnes qui sont concernées par
des plaintes pour violences sexuelles
bah écoutez moi j'ai observe d'ailleurs
que ça devient maintenant systématique
et et les plaintes dont vous parlez on
en parle aucune fois les gens nommés au
gouvernement
dans une présidence de la commission des
finances de l'assemblée exemple
été président du groupe heller à
l'assemblée nationale il se passait rien
il est membre nommé monde des médias de
la politique j'en sais rien de
l'éducation c'est ce qui est dénoncé
notamment la fac au cred moi je sais pas
d'où vient tout ça sur des faits vieux
de dix ans mais on découvre on apprend
et on lit que voilà il ya des
accusations bon moi je crois quand même
que dans ce pays on a une justice et à
elle si elle est saisie de faire son
travail et moi je crois au principe
j'allais dire de
de non culpabilité tant que vous n'êtes
que sinon je veux dire on instruit des
plaintes on s'appuie sur des plaintes
mais pas sur des condamnations à ce
tarif là je veux dire chaque fois que
quelqu'un va être nommé quelque part on
va le soupçonner de je ne sais quoi et
on va dire non maintenant il faut plus
qu'une salle se doivent pas empêcher les
nominations à des postes clés par
écouter sur coquerel la dame qui
visiblement
se plaindre lui elle s'adresse à son
parti s'adresse pas la justice et
adresse à son parti c'est quand même
formidable a dit qu'elle a déposé une
pré plainte en ligne oui vous dites il
faut se tourner vers la justice ces
affaires ne doive des partis mais devant
la justice voilà j'ai dire sinon il n'y
a plus de règle je pense qu'il ya un
principe de base il faut que la justice
soit saisie et puis s'il ya des faits
qui sont établis s'il ya une
condamnation
vous allez commencer l'examen des textes
évidemment ça y est premier miné par
l'assemblée et par le sénat c'est le
texte sur le colis des ce qu'il faut
prolonger pour vous l'état d'urgence
l'état d'urgence chose les chiffres
montrent quand même que on est
susceptible à nouveau de faire face à
une vague importante je crois qu'il faut
prendre toutes sortes de précautions
aujourd'hui on en est aux préconisations
le port du masque dans les transports
publics ça me paraît être
préconisations simple préconisations
mais pas obligation ou encore parce que
moi recréer des polémiques j'ai
peut-être pas indispensable de rajouter
ce problème là mais en tous les cas il
faut prendre des mesures c'est le rôle
des pouvoirs publics
moi je souscris pleinement tout ça est
ce qu'il faut revenir aux bases actions
à l'opas sanitaire c'est pas dans le
texte pour le moment mais ce que pour ça
doit rester à doha il faut pas y revenir
pas pour l'instant donc c'est un texte
très allégée finalement oui et ça vous
convient
écoutez ça va très bien comme ça
maintenant s'il faut prendre d'autres
mesures ont je dirais que
malheureusement m'attendent à l'habitude
le texte qui va arriver alors ça cet axe
qui est très attendue par les français
c'est le texte sur le pouvoir d'achat on
connaît déjà certaine mesure la
revalorisation des prestations sociales
des pensions de retraite notamment est
ce que cette tente est ce que vous
pourriez voter d'abord j'aimerais
l'avoir parce que j'ai dû des des
papiers notamment dans les échos sur ce
sujet c'est formidable heureusement
qu'il ya des journalistes qui obtiennent
les textes parce que nous on l'a pas
donc je peux pas vous en parler sur le
principe je peux vous dire que voilà ça
fait partie c'est un détail mais c'est
dire si un gouvernement veut travailler
avec des forces politiques au parlement
faut déjà qu'on puisse travailler sur
des textes on n'a pas les textes bon
oui après ils sont dans la presse
voilà
donc on est obligé de faire ex qu'on a
puis va y avoir beaucoup de choses qui
vont être réglés par voie réglementaire
on connaît pas ça non plus donc moi je
crois que d'abord un il faut que ça soit
ciblée sur les familles les personnes
qui en ont besoin
pas général deuxièmement il faut que ça
soit réglé dans le temps s'est pas agi
tam aeternam et troisièmement il faut
voir les économies budgétaires qu'on
peut faire en parallèle parce qu'on a un
grave problème budget pour les plus
modestes parce que les élèves il alerte
sur le fait qu'il faut pas oublier les
classes moyennes oui ça dépend où on met
le curseur le problème c'est qu'on peut
pas continuer à déverser des milliards
ça va être le cas plusieurs dizaines de
milliards alors qu'on a déjà trois mille
milliards de dettes que on a un déficit
abyssal il faut quand même commencé à
avoir une trajectoire financière
notamment sur la question du carburant
soit aujourd'hui état subventionne le
plat des carburants des français il faut
poursuivre ou pas oui on peut pas
s'arrêter maintenant simplement il faut
commencer en même temps à avoir une
réflexion sur la trajectoire
budgétaire moi avec mon groupe par
exemple on est favorable à taxer les
super profits des énergéticiens on voit
que il ya des sociétés qui font des
profits absolument considérable de
l'expression est qualifiée est ce que je
constate simplement c'est qu'il ya des
profits extrêmement importants générés
par la situation bah il est normal
qu'ils aient une partie qui reviennent à
la collectivité puisque on est obligé
au niveau 2 des français de faire un
effort pour les aider à partir en
vacances à travailler tous les jours
avec leur voiture donc il n'est pas
anormal que total c'est ma etc soit axé
sur ces supers profits est-ce que vous
avez des gnons julien olivier marleix
que celle a écrit une lettre à elisabeth
bornes avec les priorités les lignes
rouges dès lors quelles sont les vôtres
écoutez nous on n'a pas de ligne rouge
on va examiner encore une fois on va
attendre de connaître les propositions
du gouvernement qui lui même n'est pas
encore nommé à l'heure où nous parlons
donc on est dans l'hypothèse je dirais
gt1 voilà tiens puisqu'on parle du
remaniement donne olivier veyrenc émises
et relations avec le parlement au porte
parolat ça ça ça serait une bonne chose
mais ça m'est égal je veux dire il peut
être nommé n'importe où c'est pas le
sujet alors c'est de savoir quel pays
qu'est ce que c'est comme gouvernement
qu'est ce qu'ils proposent pour les
français et sur quelle majorité il peut
s'appuyer pour faire voter c'est à aix
après le petit jeu savoir qui est nommé
à quel endroit voilà on est dans un
système j'allais dire c'est le principe
du dha ville de paris quoi fluctuat nec
mergitur il flotte et mais ne sombre pas
vous voilà c'est ce que doit rechercher
la première ministre pour finir sur ces
questions de pouvoir d'achat vous avez
sans doute entendu michel edouard
leclerc qui demande une commission
d'enquêté parce qu'ils ne se demande
d'où vient cette inflation
la moitié des hausses de prix sont liées
à la spéculation dit il le sénat a déjà
commencé à réfléchir à une méthode est
ce que vous pourriez soutenir une
commission denquête commission denquête
on en parle et c'est sophie primas avec
la commission des affaires économiques y
travaille déjà sur ces sujets là avec
l'ensemble des commissaires de sa
commission et je pense que c'est un
sujet qu'il faut qu'on regarde
effectivement qui pourra prendre la
forme de commissions dans quatre sites
devraient pourquoi pas c'est à
déterminer dans l'est dans les jours qui
vont venir ce qui est sûr c'est que il
faut pouvoir je voulais dit taxer les
super profits il faut également regarder
les doubles impositions je vais pas
rentrer dans la technique budgétaire
mais entre les seychelles et tva etc etc
on a beaucoup de double imposition
notamment sur les problèmes de
succession je crois qu'il faut relancer
c'est aussi des sujets que nous
défendons les problèmes de fraude on a
déversé beaucoup d'argent ces deux
dernières années il ya aussi des gens
qui ont profité j'allais dire de façon
indue des mânes qui ont été versés et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
continuer à combattre ce mal endémique
et la fraude la démarche de michel
edouard leclerc vous la comprenez vous
pensez que c'est justifié me lancer une
enquête sur les causes réelles de
l'inflation en france à écouter on a
voté une loi qui s'appelle et galim dont
on a pu voir quels étaient
insatisfaisantes il ya des mécanismes
qui font que chaque fois qu'on aide par
exemple les producteurs et les
revendeurs
répercute en quelque sorte
ce que ce que ce qu'on donne en français
considérant que bah si on vous donne 1
10 euro ils peuvent tenir compte de ces
10 euros dans leur facturation et se les
répartir je crois que c'est c'est bon de
revenir sur l'ensemble de ces
dispositifs de compléter la loi et galim
de façon à ce qu' il n'y ait pas de
bénéfices indus dans des périodes comme
celle-ci juste un dernier mot sur ce
qu'on a compris votre attachement aux
économies il faut les faire rouler
il faut revenir sur le problème des
fonctionnaires il faut revenir sur le
problème des collectivités par exemple
supprimés fonctionnaire il va falloir
revenir à une réflexion sur les
structures des collectivités parce que
et des ministères on voit bien que il ya
beaucoup de postes notamment dans les
administrations centrales alors que on
manque de postes sur le terrain il faut
revenir à cette réflexion de la même
façon
oui en partie et puis par exemple le
président de la république annoncé qu'il
voulait faire supprimer la redevance
télévision je suis pas totalement sûr
que ce soit une bonne chose parce que on
va peut-être supprimer la redevance télé
mais on va j'allais dire les 3 milliards
5 le coût de cette mesure on va être
obligé d'aller les chercher sur les
collectivités territoriales
et ça c'est pas une bonne chose il faut
continuer à protéger les collectivités
c'est notamment le rôle des sénateurs
parce que les collectivités en
particulier les communes constituer un
amortisseur social les cantines l'aide
aux personnes âgées
qu'ovide donc on peut pas des habits et
paul pour des pierres donc prendre des
mesures comme celle là est porté
atteinte au budget des collectivités
territoriales c'est pas une bonne chose
avant sur un texte que la majorité
présidentielle reporté une composition
de la constitutionnel pour faire rentrer
le droit à l'avortement dans la
constitution est ce que ça c'est un
texte sur lequel vous pourriez voter est
ce que vous êtes favorable
sur le fond bien sûr la défense du droit
à l'avortement on y est attaché c'est
simone veil qui a porté stakes et de
votre famille politique ce qui était à
l'origine pour ça que c'est étonnant que
votre réponse des centristes soient pas
plus claire plus que soit le fond c'est
l'opportunité oui je veux dire on
mélange tout on nous dit vas y avoir une
commission transpartisane qui va
travailler sur la réforme de la
constitution sur la réforme des
institutions bien sur le coup on dit
tiens on va toucher à la constitution
sur ce sujet là et puis avant nous avait
dit ah bon on va mettre quelque chose
également sur l'environnement et puis je
suis fière tous les mois on peut avoir
comme ça une idée
de façon à médiatiser un sujet je pense
qu'il faut se poser un petit peu et
puisse toucher à la constitution c'est
ça n'est pas rien c'est important je
pense pas que le droit à l'avortement
soit menacé aujourd'hui en france on
peut attendre quelques semaines quelques
noms on peut travailler tranquillement
pour savoir s'il faut le mettre dans la
constitution s'il ya d'autres choses à m
et qu'est-ce qu'il faut réformer c'était
la proposition du chef de l'état et je
pense que tout le monde est prêt à y
travailler un mot sur le cumul des
mandats alors ça c'est vous aviez porter
un texte sur cette question de retour au
cumul des mandats et hier karl olive qui
est député de la majorité présidentielle
et qui a dû quitter la mairie de poissy
pour rentrer à l'assemblée dit qu'il
faut et député maire est ce que vous
vous demandez à la nouvelle assemblée de
voter ce texte
écoutez je ne rencontre que des gens qui
sont favorables au
choix pas toujours qu'ils veulent le
voter
et donc c'est formidable donc vous lui
dites il faut aller jusqu'au bout de la
logique
ma proposition là celle-là ou une autre
qui permet de rattacher le parlement au
territoire c'est l'idée alors après le
curseur on peut le dire
ça va jusqu'à dix mille habitants
c'était ma proposition ça va jusqu'à
50000 habitants etc etc c'est un débat à
voir mais le principe du cumul me paraît
indispensable
même le chef de l'état l'avait dit
pendant la campagne
donc il faudrait quand même mettre en
adéquation
les idées et les lois tout le monde y
est favorable
votants le pour vos principal écueil
aujourd'hui du non cumul des mandats
c'est quoi c'est la coupure entre le
monde parlementaire et le monde
territoriale et on voit bien qu'il ya
deux mondes parallèles
de toute façon il ya on est en pleine
hypocrisie ministre de la défense il est
président du conseil général de l'eure
et un parlementaire ils peuvent faire il
peut pas être maire d'une commune de 300
habitants
cherchez l'erreur déjà vous dites que
sébastien cornu
que tout le monde puisse être
par le bon coeur un mot sur jean
christophe lagarde président de votre
parti un guide et
il ya une affaire la sphère corbières
garrido un journaliste du point a porté
plainte contre jean-christophe lagarde
qui l'accusent de manipulation c'est lui
qui aurait été sa source dans sept ans
cette histoire est ce qu'il ya une
vengeance politique de la part de jean
christophe lagarde contre raquel garrido
qui l'a battu aux législatives
c'est strictement rien je suis incapable
de vous répondre j'ai pas de commentaire
à faire il ya une plainte qui a été
déposée il y aura une instruction
j'imagine mois jean christophe est un
ami donc j'ai rien n'est bon je
crois qu'il a pris du recul
après les élections législatives il
souhaite se reposer et réfléchir avec sa
famille restée à la tête de l'ue des
entre cette affaire
c'est le congrès qui en décidera
toujours est il que à sa demande au
dernier bureau politique je crois que
c'était le 21 juin le bureau m'a nommé
président délégué de l'uwe dei pour que
je puisse assumer la responsabilité de
l'ue dei lui il a souhaité prendre du
recul bon bah écoutez je lui souhaite
d'abord de se rétablir parce que c'est
jamais agréable de vivre une défaite et
puis mais vous pourriez rester vous
auriez envie de rester très en vue des
jeux
moi je je je suis pas tellement dans ce
genre de deux trajectoires politiques
entendent et président délégué de
marseille on a envie d'être président
oui mais bon je le fais avec mes amis
moi je vous savez très bien j'aime pas
trop la lumière je travaille
discrètement donc gérer ça avec mes amis
et puis on essaiera de faire les
meilleurs choix et sur quelle ligne est
ce que vous voulez que des restes avec
les alertes puisqu'à l'heure actuelle
vous êtes allés avec les leurs ou est ce
que vous regardez plutôt du côté
d'horizon partiez d'or philippe non on
est indépendant
on a eu
régulièrement des alliances avec les
républicains on a eu également d'autres
alliances et donc on souhaite
on souhaiterait souhaite rester
indépendant et travailler j'allais dire
en indépendance en autonomie sur les
textes sur les alliances au moment où ça
se présente en tous les cas c'est la
réflexion qu'on aura à l'automne parce
que par principe on souhaite pas
aller ni vers les uns envers les autres
on va travailler tranquillement et fer
au congrès ce que nous devons faire avec
l'ensemble des adhérents merci merci
fabrice
[Musique]